fine before the senate and facing some
tough questions about the russia
investigation
comey pressed on if he was asked
if he was proud of what happened watch
i'm not sure i can apply a number scale
but i would say in the main it was done
by the book it was appropriate and it
was essential that it be done
okay so you're proud of it
overall i'm proud of the work there are
parts of it that are concerning which
i'm sure we'll talk about but overall
i'm proud of to work
dana there are parts of it that are very
concerning and we've already seen the
inspector general's report we're waiting
for
another report from a u.s attorney
so does james comey really have a leg to
stand on one of those long giraffe legs
when he talks about you know in you know
the main being
proud of the investigation he has a way
with words
and there's a lot of words there's so
many words there's so many reports
there's so many hearings or so many
investigations
it is very hard to keep the thread on
all of this
i think something smells fishy i'm not
exactly sure what it is
um i could i could accidentally i could
guess but you can't guess in this
business like this is really serious
so here's what i do i just wait for the
durham report because i think that's the
final
say i think you're absolutely right and
and james comey juan has been really
good
about you know writing books about his
time at the fbi uh when he's
had public testimony about this he's
been very factual and very specific
but i don't know what happened i don't
know if if he's fallen and he can't get
up
but he couldn't seem to remember
anything today i thought that was very
odd
you know what i i think there's so many
conspiracy theories about these things
bouncing around i just get tired of it
i mean literally uh you know john
ratliff the
director of national intelligence he
puts out this report says well this is
something that the russians could have
fabricated
we can't confirm it but the fbi should
have investigated comey and then why
didn't they look into this while they
were looking into charges about trump
and the russians
and then you think well why is he's
putting this out now
we know that the senate bipartisan
intelligence committee said there was
nothing to this
putting it out now because what happened
to happen again no they're putting it
out now terrifying for
all americans they're putting it out
right now in the middle of a campaign
in which russia is again interfering to
help donald trump another conspiracy oh
no
there's no conspiracy that we have
evidence of that all right
so john brennan cia director they pick
up chatter from the russians it's saying
hillary
is trying to concoct a scheme to tie
president trump to hacking
her email server in order to distract
from
her email gate right so he then briefs
the president
and then he briefs james comey james
comey says he doesn't remember the
briefing
and we actually now have the handwritten
notes from john brennan so if juan
i wouldn't get too far out ahead of this
because when the president
declassifies the handwritten notes from
brennan the cia director
saying this is what we picked up and
this is what i told the president
and then it matches exactly what
happened that hillary did frame
donald trump for hacking her website and
her
server you are then it all comes
together i think you are we actually
so one okay i'm far gone i'll remember
that you do remember you know what i
declassified the handwritten i'll tell
you why you should remember what will
you say
would you apologize oh my gosh it's like
a debate all over again
cia get the fbi get all of our
intelligence committees
said this doesn't exist to apologize
what does it exist that
that russia made up this stuff about the
ukraine working okay
okay so then was the source of the
dossier made up too because that was
also a russians
you're so far out i'm afraid from the ig
we're going to put a lid on the ig
report because because greg's got to
take us home
have we have we is there any solution
inside or could this very thing happen
again
i think that it would be really awesome
if acb was married to james comey
because then her name would be amy
coney comey anyway this is one of those
moments where you can see how the media
can make
stories appear and then disappear so we
were uh
deluded deluded no deluged with
the russian dossier for three years
because they wanted that in the front of
our brain pan
right but stories like this they don't
stories like omar where did the omar
story go just
disappeared story we're the only people
talking about biden hunter biden that is
that disappears so they can control
what's they have the levers and this is
another example